قطع التيار الكهربائي عن مدن الاوكرانيه
وروسيا تقول ان دبابات امريكا والمانيا
اهداف مشروعه
في جنين ومقتل فلسطينيين على ايدي القوات
الاسرائيليه بعد اقتحامها المخيم
الصين تعلن تراجعا كبيرا في الوفيات اليوم
منذ بدايه يناير الجاري
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا منعطف حاسم قد يكون في مسار
الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه بعد اعلان واشنطن
وبرلين رساله دبابات التي تعيش حاله من
التاهب استعدادا لاي رده فعل روسيه وتعصبا
لاي هجمات جديده اعلنت السلطه الاوكرانيه
قطع التيار
الكهربائيو العربيه
هذا هو اعلن الجيش حاله التاهب تحسبا
لغارات جويه في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا لا
سيما في مناطق ديني برو وميكو لايف وخرطور
اضافه الى زابولجيا وخيرسون
العربيه رائد الاخضر اهلا بك رائد كما
حدثنا رائد هناك حديث عن تحضير روسيا
لهجوم كبير في مناطق في دمياط خاصه
ودعوات ايضا للاستعداد ما المتوفر لك او
المعطيات المتوفر لك حول ذلك رايت
نهاركم طيب احمد بالفعل هناك تصعيد كبير
تطورات على الصعيدين السياسي والميداني
العسكري على الصعيد السياسي التصريحات
الناريه التي اطلقها نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي دب متر مدفيدف بعدها اعلان الغرب
امداد اوكرانيا بالدبابات ليوبارد وافراما
الامريكيه والالمانيه قال بان المساس
بدوله نوويه خطر كبير على العالم قال ايضا
بان دوله نوويه عظيمه مثل روسيا من
المستحيل ان تخسر الصراعات كبيره وان همم
يعني اوكرانيا ستعزل عن البحر الاسود
الحديث يشير الى امكانيه الجيش الروسي
سيطر على قدسه واطلالته على البحر الاسود
لكن على الصعيد الميداني عمليا بالفعل
اولا انخفضت وتيره القصف الاوكراني على
مدينه دانيسك كانت 454
بشكل يومي تس على المدينه اليوم نتحدث عن
سبعه وسبعين قذيفه و80 قذيفه همم لا خسائر
بشريه ثلاثه اصابات وعده ابنيه اا اصابها
الضرر يعني المراقبون يرجعون ذلك الى همم
يعني امكانيه الجيش الروسي بدفع القوات
الاوكرانيه للابتعاد عن المناطق المتاخمه
للعاصمه دانيسك ومن طرف اخر هناك من يقول
بان مستودعات الذخيره لدى الطرف الاوكراني
قد انخفضت بعد استهداف الجيش الروسي لهذه
المستودعات نعم على الصعيد الميدان فعلا
ما زالت القوات الروسيه قواتنار تطوق
مدينه باخم في الناحيه الشماليه من دنيتك
وتحاول اقتحامها من ناحيتين الناحيه
الشماليه بعد سندار ومن الناحيه الجنوبيه
الغربيه بعد ان سيطرت على بلده كلشبكه
تتقدم نحو بلده ايفانكا وتدخل في العمق
همم الاوكراني في مدينه باخ متونات حرب
همم شوارع قتال شوارع ما بين قوات باغنر
والقوات الاوكرانيه على اطراف المدينه لكن
داخل المدينه في العمق الاوكراني هذا من
جانب الجانب الاخر الجنوب منطقه دانياس
بالفعل القوات المواليه لروسيا او دعنا
نتحدث القوات الروسيه لانها كلها تنطوي
تحت اسم الجيش الروسي همم بالفعل تطوق
مدينه اوغلادار هذه مدينه اوغلدار ما بين
اذا تذكر احمد تطوقها وتستعمل الاله
العسكريه الثقيله اي المدافع والصواريخ
وتقصف المدينه وتحاول اقتحام مدينه
اوغلودار ايضا المدينه
وايضا مدينه
معارك ضاريه جدا حرب شوارع في مدينه
يحاول الجيش الروسي اقتحامها بالفعل هناك
تصعيد في جميع نواحي مقاطعه ننتقل الى
جنوب طبعا ربما يسمح لنا الوقت جنوب
اوكرانيا هناك خلصون وج- وزبره في زبرو
جمازالت القوات الروسيه تتقدم من المحور
الجنوبي الشرقي وتسيطر على الاراضي كان
الحديث امس عن حوالي 15 كلم دخل فيها
الجيش الروسي وسيطر على عده بلدات منها
اريحا وبنى قواعد عسكريه له وينوي التقدم
للسيطره على كامل المقاطعه بينما يقول همم
يعني همم رئيس مجلس اداره السلطات هناك
بان الجيش الاوكراني حشد اكثر من 40,000
مقاتل من اجل العوده ودفع الجيش الروسي
للانسحاب من المناطق الجنوبيه من المقاطعه
ولذلك المعارك مستعره وتصريحات ناريه من
الطرفين بعد اعلان الغرب امداد الاجانب
الاوكراني بالدبابات وذلك الى هذه
المعلومات الميدانيه حرب
هذا ما سمح بيقصف لك من دونياس كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه رائدا الاخضر شكرا رايت
مشاهدينا قالوا المستشار الالماني الحرب
في اوكرانيا لن تنتهي قريبا وشدد الشمس
على فعل على فاعليه الدبابات اليوبارت 2
التي اعلنت برلين تتوي ذكيه بها مؤخرا
واضاف انه لا ينبغي للجانب الروسي ان
يتوقع ضعف الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا شغلت من
جهه ثانيه اكد ان حلف الناتو لا يريد ان
يصبح مشاركا مباشره في الصراع مع روسيا
من جهته قال رئيس لجنه الشؤون الدوليه
على الاستيلاء على القرم او تغيير مسار
العمليه الروسيه الخاصه واضاف سلوتيسكي ان
اي محاوله الاستيلاء على شبه جزيره القرم
ستلقى ردا قاسيا حسب قوله كما اشار الى ان
جميع الدبابات الامريكيه او الالمانيه
التي اعلن عن توريدها ستصبح اهدافا مشروعه
للجيش الروسي
طالب
رئيسكي دول الغرب تزويد بلاده بصوارخ
بعيده المدى ومقاتلات وذلك اثرا ووافقت
واشنطن وبرلين على ارسال دبابات ثقيله
الاكياف وقال جيلنسكي ان دحر القوات
الروسيه مرهون بحجم الدعم الدفاعي لقواته
ينسى السلطه
وهذا امر مهم لانه يجب ان وسع تعاوننا في
مجال الدفاع
فتزويدنا بهذه المقاتلات سيحقق هذا الهدف
كلما زاد الدعم الدفاعي الذي يتلقاه
جنودنا كان انتهاء العدوان الروسي اقرب
وكان الضماناتنا وضمانات الشركائنا
الامنيه اكثر من فوقيه بعد الحرب
وفي ردنا على سؤالي للعربيه قال المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون
كيربي ان رئيس بعيد الملتزم بمساعده
الاوكرانيين للدفاع عن انفسهم ضد اي
عمليات هجوميه يخطط لها
الروسيا ولا اعلم ما تخطط له وما هي نوايا
قادتها ولكن ما نتوقعه وان الرئيس بوتين
يستغل الشتاء للتحضير للعمليات العسكريه
من خلال اعاده تدريب قوته وتجهيزها
بالعداد استعدادا لمعارك الربيع لذا نحن
حريصون على استغلال هذه الفتره من اجل
مساعده الاوكرانيين في حربهم ضد روسيا لقد
سمعت الكثير من الانتقادات عندما كنت في
البلدان
المنتقدون لا يفكرون بالمستقبل البعيد
هناك الكثير من الكلام ولكن نحتاج للتركيز
على الواقع الحالي قرار اليوم يؤثر على
مدى التزام الرئيس تجاه اوكرانيا وكيف كلف
طريق الامن القومي بالتحضير والتحديد لمس
شكراين على الانتصاب
نشاطره مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
مسؤولون امميون يستعون الى تخفيف قيود
طالبان على النساء في افغانستان وتحذير من
مجاعه تلحف الافق
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد قتيلان وخمسه
جرحى فلسطينيين على يد القوات الاسرائيليه
في الاشتباكات العنيفه التي شهدها مخيم
جنين قبل الساعات هو وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه وكشفت مصادر امنيه لوكاله
الانباء الفلسطينيه بان القوات
الاسرائيليه اقتحمت مدينه
واعتلت اسطح المنازل في المخيم ما ادى الى
اندلاع مواجهه اطلق خلالها بل اطلق خلال
جنود الرصاصه وقنابل الغاز واكدت المصادره
ان القوات الاسرائيليه قطعت التيار
الكهربائي عن المخيم ومنع الطلاق من
الاسعاف والصحافينا من دخوله
اعلنا رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه بمجلس
النواب الامريكي مايكل ماكول ان المجلس
رامر قرارا باغلبيه ساحقه يشيد بشجاعه
المحتاجين الايرانيين مشيرا الى ان هذا
قرار يعيد التاكيد بقوه على دعم الشعب
الامريكي للشعب الايراني الذي يتحدث عن
نيهان ضد انتهاكات حقوق الانسان التي
يرتكبها النظام واكل على ضروره الاستثمار
في بذل المزيد لدعم حق الشعب الايراني في
تقرير
عضو البرلماني اوروبي في تغريده على تويتر
قال مرصد الامم المتحده ان النظام ايران
حكم بالاعدام على سيده كرديه حامل بتهمه
اشعل النار في صوره الخميني وهي تواجه
الاعدام الوشيك وداع مجلس حقوق الانسان
التابع الامم المتحده الى التحرك العاجل
لانقاذها
قال رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا
خالد المشري انه مستعد للقاء رئيس
البرلمان عقيل صالح في اي وقت شرطه توثيق
اي اتفاق وتوقيعه
وجدد المشري دعوته لرئيس مجلس النواب الى
مناظره مباشره على الهواء ليطرح كل طرف
رايه واضاف ان مجلس الدوله لا يملك الحق
في اصدار اي وثيقه دستوريه وكذلك لا يحق
لمجلس النواب اصدار مثل هذه الوثيقه
منفردا واكد المشري انه لن يترشح الى اي
بل لم يترشح لاي في موسم حكوميه وانه
سيقدم استقالته فهو رحل للخلاف على
القاعده الدستوريه
وجهت احزاب المعارضه البريطانيه اسئله الى
رئيس الحكومه ريشه سوناك بشان ملابسات
مزاعم التهرب الضريبي الوزير ورئيس حزب
المحافظين ناظم الزهاوي وذلك خلال جلسه
المسائل الاسبوعيه للحكومه في البرلمان
جلسه المساله الاسبوعيه للحكومه
البريطانيه كانت صعبه على
طرح حزب العمال والوطنين الاسكتلندي خمسه
اسئله تتعلق بمزاعم التهرب الضريبي لناظم
الزهاوي من دون حقيبه ورئيس حزب المحافظين
التصعيد الحاد ذهب حده وصف رئيس الحكومه
بالضعيف لرفده اقاله الزهاوي
السياسيين يسعى الى التهرب من الضرائب في
هذا البلد لا يصلح ان يكون مسؤولا عن
اموال دافعيه الضرائب
فقد اختار دعم رئيس حزب المحافظين على
الرغم من سدادته غرامه قدرها خمسه مليون
لمصلحه الضرائب
طريقه التعامله مع قضيه الزهاوي بعد نشر
الاخير بيان التسويه ضريبيه تعود للسنوات
الضاربيه غرامه بما يق وخمسه ملايين جنيه
في ما قد يكون خرقا صارخا للقواعد
الوزاريه
[موسيقى]
لم تظهر اي مشاكل معي عندما عينته في
منصبه الحالي ومنذ ان علقت على هذا الامر
الاسبوع الماضي ظهرت المزيد من المعلومات
ولهذا السبب طلبت من المستشار المستقل
النظر في هذه القضيه الان لا يمكنني الحكم
مسبقا على نتائجها ولكن من الصواب ان نحقق
في هذا الامر بشكل كامل لمعرفه جميع
الحقائق
التلفزيون
ومسؤول عن اموال الشعب يعترف بملابسات
ضرائب الشخصيه ولكنه ترك بعض الاسئله من
دون اجابه لا سيما لجهه فاتوره ضرائب
مرتبطه باسهم في شركه الراي شارك الذهاوي
في تاسيسها في العام 2000 لكنه نقل اسهمها
المقدره بس 27 مليون جنيه الى شركه مسجله
في جبل طارق باسم والده وينفي الزهاوي ان
يكون مستفيدا في هذه الشركه ويقول انا لا
علاقه له بها
معظم الزهاوي يستمر في منصبه بصعوبه بالغه
ريت ما تنتهي تحقيقاته لجه المعايير
الاخلاقيه مثل هو مثل وزير العدل دومنكراب
المتهمين بالتنمر وذلك رغم الضرر الذي
يلحقه بالمستقبل السياسي لرئيس الحكومه
رئيس السوناك مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
على ابداء مزيد من الوضوح بشان انقطاعات
الانسانيه التي يمكن اعاده فتحها امام
الموظفات الافغانيات مع تحرير احدهما من
ان ما جاحه في الافق خلال فصل الشتاء
القاسي
ضغط الامم يعلى طلبان بشان عمل الافغانيات
مسؤولان اماميان حطاطه البان بشان
القطاعات الانسانيه التي يمكن اعاده فتحها
امام الموظفات الافغانيه
افغانستان وفي بعض الاحيان لم يكن رد
الفعل لطيفا
امينه محمد نائبه الامين العام للامم
المتحده
وكالات الاغاثه اعلنت ان افغانستان تواجه
واحده من اسوء الازمات الانسانيه في
العالم اذ يهدد الجوع اكثر من نصف سكانها
الوكالات اشارت الى ان الازمه تتفاقمت
عندما منع الطالبان النساء الافغانيات من
العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه طالبان
عادت وسمحت في الاسابيع الاخيره للنساء
بالعمل في المنظمات الصحيه
[موسيقى]
في اعاده فتح المزيد من القطاعات
الانسانيه امام الموظفات الافغانيات
علق رئيس الامريكي
والانستغرام في الاسابيع المقبله واعتبر
الذي وصفه بالملحف يجب ان لا يتكرر ابدا
على رئيس امريكي
حضر مسؤولون بريطانيون من وحدات صغيره
الحجم موجوده داخل الاجهزه الالكترونيه
صينيه الصنع قد تستخدم للتجسس
ني محتمل حذر مسؤول بريطانيون من خلقه
للامن القومي وفق صحيفه تلغراف واوضح ان
التهديد المحتمل يتعدى المكونات الصينيه
التي تصنع في ابراج الهاتف المحمول والتي
ادت سابقا لحظر منتجات هواوي فبريطانيا
قليقه من قدره الصين على التجسس على
ملايين البريطانيين عبر تسريحه الرقائق
الدقيقه المدمجه في اجهزتها الالكترونيه
هذه المهمه تتم عبر ما يعرف بانترنت
الاشياء وهي وحدات صغيره لا يتعدى حجمها
خمسه سنتيمترات تستخدم في كل شيء من
الاجهزه المنزليه جاءت ذكيه الى المصابيح
والكاميرات الامنيه والسيارات وانظمه
الاسلحه المتقدمه وطبعا غيرها من المنتجات
تراقب الاستخدام وتنقل البيانات مره اخرى
الى الملك وغالبا الى الشركه المصنعه عبر
5 جي علما بان ثلاث شركات صينيه بينها
موبايل شاينا تمتلك بالفعل
54% من السوق العالميه في الاجهزه وعليها
كجميع الشركات الصينيه تسليم البيانات
للحكومه الصينيه اذا طلب من ذلك وقد فكتت
مشاهدينا الاجهزه الامنيه البريطانيه في
وقت سابق هذا الشهر سيارات وزاريه وعثرت
على جهاز واحد على الاقل مخبا داخل مكون
اخر ما زاد طبعا المخاوف من قدره الصين
على مراقبه تحركات الاهداف الاستخباراتيه
من اشخاص واسلحه وامدادات وبمقدمتها
مبيعات الاسلحه الامريكيه لتايوان
امكانيات التجسس هائله لكن المخاوف
تتعداها الى امكانيه تجديد عملاء عبر
ابتزازهم وكذلك التخريب ومهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه من خلال تعطيل الاجهزه وفقا طبعا
للتحذيرات لبريطانيا
اعلنت السلطات الصينيه تراجعا الوفيات
اليوميه الناتجه عن فيروس كورونا بنحو 80%
منذ بدايه الشهر الحالي واشتحت اكبر دوله
في العالم من حيث عدد السكان موجه اصابات
واسعه نطاق فيروس كورونا منذ ان اوقفت
بكين بشكل مفاجئ سياسه السفر كوفد وما
يترتب عليها من اجراءات صائمه
بينما يحتفل العالم بيوم التعليم تسببت من
مليشات الحوثيه بتدهور التعليم وذلك
بتحويل المدارس الى فقناه عسكريه ومنابر
للتعبئه الطائفيه
في هذا المكان المتواضع من خيام ومساكن
طينيه يسكن المعلم ومربي الاجيال علي
الوليد بمحافظه مارب بعد نجاته من قبضه
الحوثيين في مديريه الحيمه غربيه العاصمه
صنعاء حاله غيره من المعلمين اليمنيين
الذين استهدفتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه في
اطار استهدافها للعمليه التعليميه بشكل
عام قتلوا معظم المعلمين
وادخلهم الى الحبس حبسهم
وشردوهم وقطعوا رواتبهم هذا الاضرار التي
لحقت المعلم من قبل الحوثيين ثم ال-
المنهج نفسه غيره بدل ما كان منهج الوطني
غيره بالمنهج وافكار طائفيه يحتفل العالم
بيوم التعليم وقد تحولت مئات المدارس في
اليمن منذ سيطره الحوثيين على العاصمه
صنعاء قناه عسكريه وصارت مخرجات التعليم
ملغمه بافكار العنف والطائفيه والعنصريه
تساقط الى الموت في جبهات القتال
قال بنفسها ياخذونهم من المدارس الى همم
عملوا لهم عمليه غسيل الدماغ في المراكز
حقهم ثم ياخذونهم الى الجبهه ويعملوا لهم
شهائد في الجبهات بل شهائد جامعي مش اللي
همم التعليم الثانوي الاعدادي شهائد جامعي
وهم في الجبهه فدمروا العمليه التعليميه
واصبح اليمن عاد عشرات السنين الى الوراء
بمناهجه محرفه وبلا مرتبات يجبر المعلمون
تحت سطوه الحوثيين اداء عمليه تعليميه
والى مناطق سيطره الشرعيه فرك كثير منهم
لتحصين ابنائهم والتدريس هناك للحصول على
مرتبه يعول اسرهم
اضطرينا نمزح من همم بلادنا همم حيث انه
لا يوجد مرتب
وكذلك حفاظ على ابنائنا من
التعليم حفظ على ابناء المواصلات التعليم
الكبار والصغار حتى
يكملوا تعليم الدول
اريد التعليمي ومخرجاته وتتراجع العمليه
التعليميه في اليمن عقودا الى الخلف ضمن
السياسه التجهيل التي تمارسها الميليشيات
الحوثيه
وفي نهايه النشر
قطع التيار الكهربائي عن مدن الاوكرانيه
وروسيا تقول ان دبابات امريكا والمانيا
اهدافا مشروعه
اشتباكات عنيفه
فلسطينيين بل فلسطينيين على يد القوات
الاسرائيليه بعد اقتحامها المخيم
الصين تعلن تراجعا كبيره في الوفيات
اليوميه بكرونا بنحو 80% منذ بدايه يناير
الجاريه
نهايه هذه النشره مشاه
ونلتقي بعد نصف ساعه باذن الله في امان
الله
[موسيقى]